[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur tv 78
pour un nouveau numéro du 7 8 sociétés
votre rendez vous hebdomadaire où l'on
discute et on échange sur les sujets qui
font l'actualité
municipale associatifs ou privés le
soutien scolaire concerne un lycéen sur
trois et un collégien sur cinq mecs les
confinements et les courants distancia
qui ont rythmé les deux dernières années
scolaires le soutien scolaire est il
devenu un besoin plus important on en
parle avec nos invités adélaïde lopez
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes maire adjointe
déléguée à l'éducation à la ville de la
verrière manuel afonso bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes présidente de l'ape est
78e' naït yahia oui bonsoir
vous êtes fondatrice d'excellents
soutien scolaire vous êtes situé à
montigny-le-bretonneux et saraghina
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes fondatrice de
virtual classe alors la banque ont des
plaintes dont développe toutes les 5 et
je trouve un petit reportage au centre
alfred de vigny il y à des cours de
mathématiques en ce moment au petit
groupe c'est sur cinq jours bixente
mejia santesteban a assisté à l'un
d'entre eux le temps d'un accompagnement
regarder
pour les honore cette semaine chaque
matin c'est suivi de mathématiques sept
élèves de ce2 et en stage eureka au
centre alfred de vigny son professeur
est là pour l'accompagner identifier ces
difficultés la faille naîtront
italie mal puisque et à chaque fois les
citrouilles et à chaque fois chenil donc
s'il a du temps ce serait où je peux
s'est pendu but sépare la fin ce serait
peut-être en quelle période de temps
catherine bloch donne de la méthode au
centre alfred de vigny le travail se
fait en petit groupe jusqu'à cinq
enfants je fais toujours un petit lit un
petit diagnostic avec eux je demande de
voir les contrôles les cahiers de façon
intervenir là où les besoins bien sûr
que l'on en tête dans chaque année de
ces sois primaire ou collège il y a des
notions avoir plus importantes et des
caps et des compétences à acquérir
du compromis qui prend tranquillement
le centre-ville chinois propose aussi un
suivi de ses élèves tout au long de
l'année un suivi hebdomadaire pour
asseoir des progrès
manuel afonso je vais commencer avec
vous on entendu dans le reportage c'est
des travaux en petit groupe el profesor
le présente comme un cadre privilégié
est-ce que ça rassure les parents
justement ce travail en nombre réduit
est-ce que ça va sur les parents oui et
non parce que aujourd'hui ce qui
rassurerait les parents c'est qu'il
n'est pas besoin de faire appel à du
soutien scolaire pourra avoir une
arrière niveau d'instruction à à
protéger à mal bon après il est vrai que
ça sur pratique déjà dans les écoles le
temps dans ce qu'on appelle les temps
d'activités complémentaires les apc où
on prend les professeurs prennent par
petits groupes d élèves pour les aider à
développer les connaissances qu'ils ont
du mal à acquérir il est vrai que les
parents font de plus en plus appel aux
méthodes de soutien scolaire que ce soit
individualisé ou en petit groupe pour
donner les meilleures chances à leurs
enfants après de là à dire que ça
rassure bas côté on fait ce qu'on peut
pour nos enfants ils n'essaient yahiaoui
le soutien school scolaire c'est souvent
une demande faite par les parents
surtout les plus jeunes les primaires et
les collégiens est-ce qu'il est parfois
dur d'intéresser les élèves parce que
quelles sont les attentes de ses élèves
et justement nous c'est notre challenge
vraiment le challenge qu'on s'est fixés
c'est que les élèves 25 chez nous c'est
de leur propre initiative mais même
constat les patrons proposent toujours
aux parents c'est de faire un cours
d'essai
l'ours et à l'engagement
et april pour décider de leur demander
ils veulent vraiment s'inscrire chez
nous pas faudrait que pour la majorité
des élèves et viennent de leur propre
gré et ça fait une grosse différence
parce que un élève qui vient forcé
et vous permet d'être en condition
connaissances en élève qui vient parce
qu'il est volontaire et ça c'est
vraiment énormément de choses qui sont
mises en place pour qu'il se sente à
l'aise parce que ça soit dans le choix
des coachs ou même bête d'avoir une
machine âge pourquoi la chine ici
une volonté des élèves manuel afonso ça
s'explique peut-être par le ce chiffre
64 % des élèves n'ont personne pour les
aider à faire leurs devoirs à la maison
c'est énorme 64% j'aime bien savoir d'où
vient ce chiffre parce que bon il est
vrai que il est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de
familles qui se retrouvent en difficulté
que ce soit par l'organisation
personnelle professionnelle ou tout
simplement par un manque d'intérêt dans
dans le suivi de la scolarité des
enfants parce que aujourd'hui on estime
que que décollent en tout cas dans la
manière dont elle est présentée est là
pour apporter le cadre le cadre
d'enseignement et que la maison est le
lieu de loisir et de repos d'autant plus
qu'avec les lois qui sont passés
dernièrement pour l'allègement des
devoirs il ya eu un allègement
l'implication des familles dans le suivi
scolaire de l'enfant maintenant je
rejoins complètement ce que dit madame
hi hi hi hi le gros problème aujourd'hui
c'est que on a des enfants qui n'ont pas
forcément envie d'aller au delà de ce
qu'ils font à l'école le confinement n'a
pas amélioré cette situation dans le
sens où est ben ils se sont retrouvés à
la maison ils ont perdu leur père
travaille sa maison
c'est un repère qui a du mal à être
repris aujourd'hui si on fait appel à du
soutien scolaire c'est justement pour
laisser reposer ce cadre alors 64% quand
même je trouve que c'est un chiffre très
important que je ne connaissais pas
personnellement
voilà je mets ça reste une réalité qui
était envisagé en effet
à des leds lopez on l'entend donc un
chiffre qui sont très importants en 2021
la ville de la verrière lance sa
plateforme de soutien scolaire en ligne
qu'est ce qui a motivé la dce ce sont
les confinements ce sont des difficultés
qui sont remontés de parents d'élèves
peut-être de professeurs même
alors en fait sur la commune jusqu'à
jusqu'à notre élection jusqu'à notre
arrivée il n'y avait pas n'y a qu'une et
soutien scolaire
donc la technique la plus facile à
développer assez rapidement a été
effectivement le soutien scolaire en
ligne 1 ce qui nous a permis de laisser
mature et l'année 2021 pour mâturer en
vrai projet autour d'études dirigé et où
d'étude surveillée afin d'être en plus
de cette présence net pour lesquels
toutes les familles n'ont pas accès de
pouvoir d'accéder en fait que les
familles puissent accéder alors à des
études et non plus à la garderie du soir
effectivement 64% je veux voir ma
fonction ça me paraît en chiffres
énormes
que effectivement il y avait des enfants
qui pratiquait le centre de loisirs
jusqu'à 18h30
la latitude après pour pouvoir faire les
devoirs ça nous paraître c'est assez
compliqué entre le repas la douche ça
prolonger le temps de coucher donc c'est
pour cela que maintenant les les
familles ont l'opportunité d'inscrire
leurs enfants sur des études sur les
écoles de la verrière
c'est vrai que même dans l'entente des
dons qu'il faut de la volonté des jeunes
à aller à ces cours de soutien scolaire
vous la particularité c'est que ce sont
les élèves alors plutôt des étudiants
des supérettes qui s'adresse aux élèves
vous lancez virtual classe c'est toute
cette
crise l'épidémie qui vous a poussé à
créer ce format
oui totalement en fait je pense que la
crise sanitaire ça a été un élément
déclencheur de cette initiative parce
qu'en fait ça m'a permis de prendre
conscience que le soutien scolaire c'est
un réel besoin alors c'est vrai qu'en
fait hors cadre de la crise ça se
ressente mais pas trop parce que on
n'était pas chez nous et que font par
exemple comme le disait adélaïde lopez
certains allaient à l'étude dont qui
s'était accompagnée mais c'est vrai que
le fait d'être rentré chez soi chez soi
et d'être aux deux seuls finalement ça a
révélé des failles ça a montré que
certains élèves on était soit pas assez
autonomes pour pouvoir faire leurs
devoirs tout seul pour pouvoir ne pas
décrocher ou avait besoin de compagnie
comme celle dont on disposait avant la
crise donc moi en fait j'ai vu qu'il y
avait ce besoin là même de ma part c'est
pas dans les mêmes conditions et
justement la virtual classe ça a été un
moyen d'offrir des services de soutien
scolaire d'une part pour pouvoir les
accompagner scolairement mais également
moralement parce qu'il faut aussi je
pense parler de cette thématique là sa
faillite est facile pour tout le monde
moralement il ya eu beaucoup de
décrochage scolaire est juste le fait de
savoir qu'on n'est pas seul on est tous
dans le même bateau que on peut tous
s'entraider il a notamment cité des
étudiants professeurs qui donnait des
cours pour aller vers le meilleur ça
rassure donc en plus comme c'était
gratuit ça me permettait de rire ça à
plusieurs élèves parce que aussi quelque
chose qu'on n'aborde pas assez souvent
c'est que le soutien scolaire
malheureusement s'est pas ouvert à tous
le monde super voir à toutes les
familles en fonction des tarifs je sais
que dans certaines villes il ya des
initiatives qui sont mises en place mais
c'est vrai que le mettre à disposition
gratuitement ça a été un moyen d'avoir
plus de personnes parce que du coup il y
avait pas ce frein là mais c'est vrai
que la crise sanitaire ça faisait
vraiment été un élément déclencheur qui
nous a montré que finalement le soutien
scolaire c'était une nécessité oui le
soutien scolaire à un coup vous venez de
le dire le marché on a été en janvier
2020 donc bien avant la crise évalué à 2
milliards d'euros en france ils
n'essaient gaillot de nos invités vous
êtes la seule dont l'activité est
payante est ce que vous voyez des
familles faire si je peux me permettre
ce mot un sacrifice financier pour
accompagner leurs enfants
complètement complètement moi j'ai des
mamans qui viennent me voir et qui me
disent en fait je sais que ça peut
paraître
c'est pas comme on le voit les
associations et de faire payer salonique
- coup mais il faut savoir que la
qualité ça d'avoir d'autres locaux
ou des élèves se sentent à l'aise qu'ils
ne sont pas des salles municipales
presque abandonné les élèves voilà ce
sens dans un espace un peu lugubre avec
les chefs quel cd autre vocable issement
c'est complètement différent car dans de
vrais locaux design et avec sa
suspension l'élève
même le fait d'avoir le café le chocolat
chaud de café le bigfoot sa touche et
ses oies
super important alors des familles qui
viennent me voir et des mam c'est bien
de voir qu'ils disent voilà j'ai pas
forcément les moyens mais je vais pas
même me serrer la ceinture pour
promouvoir pour pouvoir inscrire au
moins grand chez vous ça arrive ça
arrive très souvent après nous mais
quand même des choses en place un peu
comme le système baguette suspendre vous
propose aux familles les plus aisées de
financer des formules aux familles les
plus en difficulté sans dans l'anonymat
le plus total que l'on puisse laisser la
chance à tous d'accéder à nos services
manuel afonso est-ce que vous avez vu
aussi emparée de thaler est ce que les
parents ça les rassure de du soutien
scolaire en petit groupe est ce que vous
avez senti aussi depuis deux ans des
parents plus inquiet mort des enfants
plus inquiet non retard
quand j'ai enfin on va jusqu'à et
terminale voire plus du retard qu'ils
ont pu prendre dans leurs études dans
leurs renseignements lors que leurs
compétences
il ya une vraie disparité entre le
premier degré et le second degré le
second degré ya quand même des objectifs
de diplômes que ce soit le bepc pour
pour les troisièmes où que ce soit le
bac pour les lycéens
l'angoissent elle vient surtout de bas
de parcours sup à l'heure actuelle qui
met une pression monstrueuse sur les
élèves qui et leurs familles qui ont du
mal à construire des dossiers
convaincant à et c'est là que tout le
soutien scolaire prend son sens parce
que bâle entre un bac qui a été réformé
il ya pas longtemps un parcours sub qui
est menée une pression et un retard
assumer enfin va assumer pardon constaté
dans les dents second degré
principalement il est clair qu'au
soutien scolaire prend tout son sens
après au niveau du premier degré les
maternelles et élémentaires se ressentit
il n'est pas aussi évident on est
conscients que nos enfants ont besoin de
rattraper un retard mais l'équipe
l'équipe pédagogique déjà se veut
rassurante en règle générale on a les
équipes municipales qui se veulent
rassurantes également en meurent en
amenant des propositions comme en avoir
les madame lopez d'études encadré et
pour le cas de montigny le bretonneux
puisque c'est là où moi j'habite on a
également un soutien scolaire qui est
proposé aux enfants du delà de de la
grande section au cm2 par la ville de
montigny on a à côté dessoudé des
organismes de soutien scolaire qui
viennent apporter en plus vous avez les
associations de parents d'élèves comme
la nôtre qui propose à ses adhérents des
actes et à des cours des professeurs en
ligne tous de l'éducation nationale par
le biais de profs express.com voilà il
ya beaucoup de moyens qui seront mis à
disposition
maintenant de là à dire qu'il ya une
inquiétude auprès des élèves elle se
sentira plus haut niveau du second degré
qu'au niveau des hanches des petits
enfants qui peut se montre plus inquiet
d'avoir du mal à jouer avec leurs amis
et de devoir supporter ce masque toute
la journée plutôt que de s'inquiéter de
leur apprentissage à l'heure actuelle
cet impact sur les secondaires on va
dire madame lopez c'est quelque chose
que vous voyez à la verrière vous avez
peut-être déjà des chiffres sur votre
plateforme de quelques cours sont les
plus suivie qu'elle demande sont les
plus fait
alors au niveau du secondaire j'ai moins
de
2 mg g - de vision puisque le collège en
l'occurrence est situé sur une autre
commune
la plateforme enseigne haut qu'on avait
mis en ligne est encore malheureusement
sous-exploité
puisque en fait nous avons à la verrière
des gens qui ont des difficultés d'accès
à
internet et ça c'est vraiment ce qui a
été mis en valeur par le compliment
c'est à dire qu'on a perdu les enfants
parce que les parents n'avaient pas
d'outils internet ou quand il ya
plusieurs enfants pour un celui qui
internet et tous les cours sont
sont en ligne ça a été vraiment la
difficulté pour le premier degré pour
l'élémentaire moi je me veux plutôt
rassurantes obligé des conseils d'école
puisque effectivement il y avait d un
petit retard qui avait été vu lors des
premières évaluations le voit
particulièrement au cp mais lors des
deuxièmes conseil d'école
vraisemblablement le retard et
a été rattrapé par les professeurs des
écoles qui font un travail formidable
qui ont réussi à remettre les enfants à
niveau malgré toutes les difficultés
c'est à dire qu'apprendre cp à la
prononciation avec un masque ou
effectivement les est le langage passe
par le visuel
à prendre les différences de son ou en
le voit avec la bouche je pense qu'ils
ont des difficultés supplémentaires mais
en tout cas le retard est récupérée pour
les collégiens et lycéens il ya eu aussi
une suite mais comme le disait même
façon ils ont le retard va se récupérer
puisque ils ont des objectifs
quand on a le brevet à la fin quand on a
le pack à la fin ça n'a pas la même
sonorité est la même ou voilà le même
impact que quand on est en développement
et en apprentissage
saraghina ne vous avez évolué aussi
petit à petit avec virtual cela c est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous proposer d'autres je
sais que selon les vacances vous
proposer aussi des entretiens des
préparation aux entretiens en blanc et
tout ça on est on s'adapte aussi à
chaque situation quand on fait du
soutien scolaire
qu'au début on
s'attardait vraiment sur les stages
intensifs en faisant toutes les matières
parce qu'en fait j'avais un besoin dans
toutes ces matières l'ajustement vu
qu'il n'y avait pas à ce moment-là
l'aide cours en visioconférence par tous
les professeurs donc on s'est adapté à
la situation n'a fait ça en
visioconférence d'une part parce que
c'était obligatoire finalement pouvait
pas faire autrement nos clients déjà on
s'est adapté sur le côté technique mais
également sur la demande donc des élèves
mais également
de tout ce qui se faisait finalement à
ce moment là c'est à dire le brevet donc
moi quand j'étais pendant le confinement
on s'était adapté à la demande des
élèves donc on faisait des préparations
brevets des stages intensifs mais
également des cours en tout genre et
maintenant la situation et a évolué en a
moins de confinement quand il ya des
confinement on reprend du coup les
stages intensifs mais sinon en général
voilà on essaie de voir ce qui se passe
par exemple la ja d euros donc en
terminale mais également en première
avec le même des français donc on
propose justement déception
doro blanc parce que avec le confinement
les gens ont perdu justement ce lien
social ou par le moins donc on est moins
habitué finalement à la prise de parole
et c'est également un moyen finalement
de reprendre cette habitude mais
également de les former pour l'épreuve
du bac de français depuis en fait on est
en constante évolution finalement en
fonction des avis mais également des
demandes des autres et on c'est pour ça
qu'au final dans le futur on élargira
nos services à plusieurs niveaux n'est
pas que à la première ou au troisième il
ne s'est avoué j'attaque du soutien
scolaire dans votre établissement à vous
proposer depuis novembre dernier des
ateliers de côte de coaching pardon
c'était ce qu'on dit depuis tout à
l'heure on évolue on n'est pas là que
pour les notions on donne de la méthode
bien sûr mais on accompagne l'élève de
manière plus large exactement à son app
est excellent structure de nos bases
notre particularité c'est notre méthode
d'enseignement innovantes qui est
beaucoup basé sur la fonction françois
et le développement personnel et donc on
a trouvé ça est dans la continuité des
travaux de ce qu'on faisait
d'organiser des ateliers coaching
là vraiment on n'est plus trop de la
transmission connaissance qu'on va pas
parler mathématiques on voit pas contre
les chroniques chimie on va plutôt
parler confiance en soi gucci petite
vidéo comment on apprend à se connaître
comment rectifier parce qu'en fait ce
qu'il faut conforter les élèves de
l'autre jour ils sont complètement
déconnectés de leurs réalités de leur
avenir ils comprennent pas le pourquoi
de l'école n'est pas qu'on prenne part
pourquoi ils vont à l'épaule et du coude
euros alors ce qu'on fait pendant
l'atelier sanzot détail et rousset
pouvoir remettre en question les cols on
va imaginer un monde sans école pour
voir comment ça serait et déjà de ce
poète - ne je trouve que c'est super
important pour que quand ils travaillent
ils se rendent compte de pourquoi ils le
font et le pourquoi est super important
et pour moi ce sont des choses qui sont
mortelles de nos jours ils sont
malheureusement pas présente au collège
et au lycée mais voilà comme toujours on
est complémentaire à ce que ce qui est
fait par les notes nationales et/ou des
gros besoins manquant
du système actuel on essaye de pas les
miens sa venue à la photo josée vu avec
l'essai c'est une génération qui ne
voient plus l'intérêt dans l'école c'est
lié à la crise ou pas du tout vous le
vivez vous aussi à la peine depuis
quelques temps
en temps de parents que ce soit
représentants ou parents tout court moi
je me reconnais totalement dans le
discours que tient madame yahiaoui
concernant le fait que l'enfant l'élève
a du mal à à de plus en plus de mal à
comprendre l'utilité de ce qu'il apprend
au quotidien en fait c'est je pense que
c'était pas une question de placer
l'élève dans son environnement qui est
une école c'est vraiment une question de
l'enfant a du mal à comprendre pourquoi
les programmes qu'ils lui soient
imposées qu'à la caisse à quoi ça va lui
servir plus tard et là je vous parle de
l'enfant pas de l'adolescent soyons
d'accord je parle vraiment des enfants
au niveau primaire principalement et
début collège après arrive le collège le
lycée où la main commencent à prendre
conscience des enjeux de son parcours
éducatif on commence à prendre
conscience également du parcours
d'orientation dans lequel on a envie de
s'engager et là on commence à vraiment
s'impliquer dans son dans sa démarche
éducative enfin instructive en tout cas
vraiment moi je pense qu'il est
important et ça c'est vraiment un enjeu
qui est en train de se développer ça se
voit déjà au niveau des conseils de
casse de réussir à faire comprendre aux
enfants pourquoi ce qu'ils apprennent
aujourd'hui sera utile demain et comment
est ce qu ils peuvent l'inscrire dans
leur quotidien et ça encore une fois on
a les professeurs d'éducation nationale
qui sont en train de sortir des méthodes
vraiment très intéressante pour pour
inscrire par exemple l'apprentissage du
vocabulaire en travaillant un lexique
propres à un domaine de la vie je vous
donne un exemple ça pourrait être
travaillé leur cabu l'air en développant
le leak le lexique de la cuisine pour
ceux qui voudraient apprendre à cuisiner
que ça intéresse on va avoir des rallyes
problème pour comprendre en quoi la
résolution d'un problème va venir aider
le quotidien de l'enfant redonner du
sens à l'instruction c'est vraiment
important maintenant je pense que
aujourd'hui les familles elles sont
surtout inquiète de comment les diplômes
que prépare nos enfants seront valorisés
demain on est dans un flou totalement
incertain c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs il y
a un réel intérêt je pense auprès des
familles pour le soutien scolaire parce
qu'on a envie d'apporter un plus un
bonus à nos enfants par rapport à ce
qu'ils ont déjà dans leur quotidien
donner un plus à des leila lopes on a
beaucoup parlé de la plate forme depuis
le début mai sur heavy rain est un pas
que ça comme de nombreuses vies il ya
des offres peut-être plus qu'à c'est
qu'il a l'air compagnon à scolarité le
club coup de pouce les temps des devoirs
la semaine de l'art aux mobilisations
scolaire c'est ça c'est un tout le
soutien scolaire s'est finalement pas
que un cahier un professeur un élève ou
ont fait de problèmes de mathématiques
on revoit de vue du vocabulaire de la
dictée lue le soutien scolaire tête en
tout et tu as ta date à chaque enfant
faire que vous allez les enfants qui
n'ont besoin uniquement d'études j'ai
pour faire le devoir vous avez des
enfants qui ont besoin de dispositifs
plus qui vont leur prendre en charge
plus dans leur globalité puisqu'il ya
d'autres problématiques
a par exemple un enfant 10
le système scolaire est pas forcément
adapté pour lui et on a mis en place les
fins et mis en place sur la commune les
classes les dispositifs coup d'pouce et
surtout le dispositif de réussite
éducative qui vont être là pour pour
donner envie d'apprendre et par des
façons détournées c'est une prise en
charge dans la globalité puisque c'est
ça qui est important
chaque enfant est différent vous avez
des enfants qui sont mobilisables
extrêmement facilement après l'école
pour lesquels l'étude va suffire et vous
avez des enfants après 16h30 c'est fini
vous pouvez plus les mobiliser c'est
extrêmement compliqué
donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya de nombreux
dispositifs sur la commune maintenant
charge à nous charge aux parents nous en
tant que parent de deux puis
d'intégrer sa et d'inscrire si on sait
que notre enfant est mobilisable de
l'inscrire aux études si on sait que
notre enfant est pas mobilisables on
l'inscrit uniquement aux centres de
loisirs et les charges à l'éducation
nationale qui fait déjà un excellent
travail avec les apc et tous les
dispositifs qu'ils ont mis en place mais
c'est à eux de nous filer chez des
enfants pour les rentrer dans ces
dispositifs très particulier qui vont
axer plus je voulais qu'ils vont prendre
en charge de façon plus globale et
parfois de façon pluridisciplinaire par
important sarah glidden vous l'avez vite
fait évoquer d'ouvrir vos cours un peu
plus large en plus vous la particularité
comme on disait c'est que ce sont des
étudiants des élèves qui parle aux
élèves et aux étudiants on retrouve
aussi cet aspect qu'on a peut-être perdu
depuis deux ans le travail entre copains
les échanges sans nécessairement passer
par un adulte un professeur référent une
stature peut-être même de hiérarchie
comme on a peu à voir à l'école c'est le
mot est un peu fort au wynn exactement
je pense que déjà en fait si j'ai choisi
des étudiants au début c'est parce que
c'était les personnes et plus
disponibles et les plus motivés
la motivation c'est un facteur important
en fait on peut avoir des professeurs
qui sont experts en la matière mais
voilà au niveau de la pédagogie de la
motivation
la verrerie et quand on a quelqu'un qui
même s'ils ne maîtrisent pas la
perfection son sujet est motivé il sera
vraiment donné l'envi tout d'abord à
l'élève de s'intéresser à la matière ce
qui est très important parce qu'en fait
si on commence à rentrer tout de suite
dans le vif du sujet avec des données
des chiffres on va pas intéresser les
élèves et ça c'est une problématique à
prendre en compte donc déjà en fête avec
les étudiants ils sont motivés donc ça
facilite les choses mais comme vous le
dites y'a pas cette hiérarchie est ce
qu'en fait en général quand on est dans
une classe après ça dépend des
confesseurs on a notre statut d'élève le
professeur à son statut qui est en
général supérieure donc ont agi avec
diplomatie et cette variable à elle même
au niveau des questions je pense que
déjà l'une des raisons de l'échec
scolaire simplement la timidité des f il
va pas à poser certaines questions qui
paraissent est selon lui et il va
accumuler ces lacunes et finalement il
va pas s'en sortir alors qu'ici quand on
est avec un étudiant on est plus à
l'aise et on sera plus apte à lui poser
des questions et donc à progresser et
justement je trouve que renouer
finalement ce lien entre des étudiants
c'est super intéressant parce que ça
peut autant apporter des bienfaits à
hasnon en tant qu'élève mais également
aux étudiants parce que quand on
transmet finalement on apprend donc c
est aussi très intéressant sur ce point
là alors je vous propose qu'on s'arrête
sur ces mots on aurait pu en parler
encore longtemps du soutien scolaire
mais le temps file
merci à toutes les 4-12 être rendus
disponibles sur ce temps des changes de
cette société maintenant terminée on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau temps d'échangé d'ici là bien
sûr prenez soin de vous
[Musique]
tout faux